I don't even know if the video is still
up um but I just saw that Luke tweeted
it out that he reposted a clip of RFK
talking with Rogan I imagine from that
show or from the episode and that
YouTube is like your entire channel is
now demonetized yeah so not just that
video is the entire channel that is
really harsh that is really harsh and it
takes a lot for me to say that about
anything that happened to Luke that's
rough yeah yeah it's sad to sympathize
with Luke but I'm going to because I
stand up for all all Americans and All
Humans Free Speech must Prevail
there are better reasons there are
better reasons to to you know clamp down
on Luke he's he's off of this I I think
I don't think what he did here is uh
so we now see that we now see that Joe
Rogan uh he made the huge offer that's
got massive on Twitter uh Tim Prime was
offering money hundreds of thousands of
dollars I think it's up to 1.2 million
the last time I checked of money that
would be donated to charity